pete davidson earns brownie points with
girlfriend kim kardashian's family by
sending her sister chloe flowers on
valentine's day i love that the good
american founder marked the holiday by
sharing a look at all the goodies she
received on instagram including flowers
from her sister courtney's daughter
penelope momager kris jenner plus sister
kylie jenner her man travis scott and
their two kids stormy and wolf but this
is the arrangement that caught our eye
the one from her sister's boob pete yep
the snl star sent coco pink roses she
thanked him in the caption writing quote
the sweetest i feel so lucky the 28 year
old comedian has gotten to know chloe
since he and kim started dating back in
october the two first linked up after
she made her saturday night live hosting
debut now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
chloe was there for the big night
starring in a sketch of her own with the
beauty mogul and their mom
thank god i'm back to being kim
good you know what i knew something was
off totally agree my daughters hey let's
get this [ __ ] out
i'm not 80. it's me it's mom i'm chris
jump to january and khloe pete and kim
all hung out at an escape room in la
it's a beautiful thing as for how chloe
spent her v-day after admiring all her
gifts the single mom enjoyed some
quality time with her daughter
[Music]
the true star also made time to work out
sharing this snap of her blowing kisses
from the gym i love to work out and i
love to just like that's my selfish time
and we know working out is chloe's way
of de-stressing which we're guessing
she's been in need of lately she's
currently dealing with the aftershocks
of a scandal with true's dad her ex
tristan thompson in december news broke
that the nba star fathered a child with
personal trainer marilyn nichols while
still dating chloe tristan denied the
fact but a paternity test later proved
that he is marylee's son's dad the
basketball player then publicly
apologized to khloe i'm someone who i do
like to put my relationships as a
priority and i try to make i really try
to make that work as for what's next for
chloe a source tells et the 37 year old
is ready to write a new chapter
she is in a great healthy space
physically mentally and spiritually my
revenge is not towards one person it's
more for
everyone who was so cruel to me
and really shunned me and it was
it's now like i have revenge on that and
revenge almost on my old self
the source adds chloe feels her
strongest when she is in a good workout
routine and it's her own way of
detoxifying multiple aspects of her life
including any drama with tristan i think
working on your personal growth
internally is something that will be a
forever
mission and i always want to evolve and
grow and mature
emotionally
because that's how we become better
people
[Music]